what is a low-cost business to start
it's a question that came in from a
reader pride pride hop i hope you
pronounce that properly newsletter
subscriber
and he wants to start a business he
doesn't know what business to start he
doesn't have a lot of money
and is trying to figure out what company
should he start and he wants me to tell
them what to do
this is a great question and
it's so important because most
entrepreneurs get this
wrong and it comes from restructuring
your thinking
because if you're just starting the
business thinking what's the business
that i can start
that doesn't cost me a lot and that can
make me money you're not going to have
success as an entrepreneur you're going
to fail you're going to shut down you're
going to be one of the 80
who never make it you have to start a
business around something that you are
intensely passionate about
you have to see something in the world
that you don't like
something that's wrong and you have a
solution to make it better
and you attack that every day until you
achieve your goal
any business can be low cost any
business can be started without spending
money
and it's something that i preach and i
believe in i hate spending money
before making money and most
entrepreneurs
hey when we're starting up we don't have
huge backing right we don't have
the rich uncle giving us tons of cash to
get started at least i didn't
i didn't have anybody rich supporting me
it was my blood sweat tears
making my first business happen every
new project that i get into
i'm not spending any money until i'm
making money on it that's the way to
live as an entrepreneur
in my first business it was a software
company and i had two partners
and we started from our apartment and
day in day out we grinded that thing out
until we started making some money
and eventually started making good money
and sold the company
now it's not as easy as that but you
have to start a business
around something you are intensely
passionate about you see
a way to change the world
and you're going to do that by creating
your business
and then once you've found what that is
what what business that is
you find the lowest cost way to get
started
because if it requires you going out and
getting a hundred thousand dollars to
launch you're never gonna do it you're
never gonna do it you're going to sit
there
on your plan trying to raise money doing
it half-heartedly and never take any
action to get this business started
start small have a huge dream but start
small do something
to launch this thing part time after
hours
get started start talking to customers
start making this thing move
start executing on your idea
don't think you need to raise a ton of
money to launch a successful company
most of
the best business in the world started
with nothing
and that's how you should start too so i
can't tell you what businesses start
every business can be started without a
lot of money and the right one that you
should start
is one you are intensely passionate
about that even when it gets super
difficult and hard and challenging
you're still going to go through because
you believe in what you're doing
that's the business to start when george
lucas
created lucasfilms and he he eventually
got onto movies like star wars
he said the first six years of his life
were total failure in business and he
thought
every day about quitting and going back
into the job and the only thing that
kept him going through it
was that he loved filmmaking he did it
because he loved it
and now he's a billionaire and it's not
just that simple
a to z it took a lot of failure along
the way but he kept going because he
loved doing it
so tap into your passion find something
that you love doing
intensely you want to change the world
with it and then find the simplest
smallest stupidest easiest
way to get started that's the business
you should start
believe for those of you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below it always makes you want to do
more for you
and i want to hear what you have to
think please leave a comment it's the
best part of my day seeing your comments
come in i'm eating my breakfast
looking at the comments it always cheers
me up and makes me want to go out and do
more
and if you have a question leave it
below and i'll do a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon